UKRAINE.
THE POWER GRID TAKING A SERIOUS
TOLL AS WINTER SETS IN.
>> Reporter: SO MANY TEARS FOR
YET ANOTHER VICTIM OF RUSSIA'S
WAR IN UKRAINE.
MOURNERS IN KYIV PAYING FINAL
RESPECTS TO A FALLEN UKRAINIAN
SOLDIER, A HUSBAND, BROTHER AND
SON.
♪
>> Reporter: HE WAS REPORTEDLY
KILLED NEAR.
INTENSE FIGHTING HAS THE CITY
ALMOST UNRECOGNIZABLE.
DEBRIS LITTERS THE STREETS.
BUILDINGS ARE ON FIRE.
>> Translator: OUR HOUSE IS
DESTROYED.
THERE IS A SHOP AND NOW IT NOT
THERE ANYMORE.
>> Reporter: IN THIS BEE
-- BAR
SIEGED CITY, MILLIONS ARE LIVING
WITHOUT POWER AND PERSISTENTLY
TARGETING UKRAINIAN ENERGY
FACILITIES GIVING ENGINEERS
LITTLE TIME TO REPAIR THE GRID
BEFORE
UKRAINE'S ENERGY MINISTER
DESCRIBES IT AS DIFFICULT.
THERE IS A POWER DEFICIT UNABLE
TO MEET THE BASIC ENERGY NEEDS
OF THE COUNTRY.
FEARS ARE GROWING AMONG
UKRAINIAN OFFICIALS, MOSCOW
COULD BE PLANNING LARGE STRIKES
AROUND NEW YEAR'S DAY.
IN THIS SMALL VILLAGE NEAR
KHERSON, PEOPLE ARE BRACING FOR
A BIT EARLY COLD WINTER, A
WINTER WITHOUT POWER COLLECTING
FIREWOOD AND OTHER SUPPLIES TO
PROTECT AGAINST PLUMMETING
TEMPERATURES.
>> Translator: WE WILL GET
THROUGH THE WINTER BECAUSE WE
FIXED THE CHIMNEY AND NOW WE CAN
HEAT THE HOUSE.
WE WILL GET THROUGH IT.
WE DO NOT HAVE ANY OTHER OPTION.
WHERE WOULD WE GO?
>> Reporter: ON TOP OF THIS A
WAR OF WORDS.
SERGEI LAVROV SAYING UKRAINE
MUST BOW TO RUSSIA'S DEMANDS OR
ELSE THE RUSSIAN ARMY WILL TAKE
MATTERS INTO ITS OWN HANDS.
UKRAINE'S PRESIDENT VOLODYMYR
ZELENSKYY SAYS THAT WON'T
HAPPEN.
HE'S VOWING TO RETAKE ALL
CAPTURED UKRAINIAN GROUND.
DIPLOMATIC NEGOTIATIONS SEEN
JUST AS GRIDLOCKED AS THE BATTLE
FIEL